yeah so my name is Jose Mesa I've been
with Anaconda about roughly eight months
um and I will go through before that I
was actually in the oil and gas industry
and before that in the airspace so I
think this thought is kind of related to
that it's like how can we navigate
career adjustments in times of
uncertainty there's a lot going on right
with the pandemic effects right while we
pass those two years in the pandemic
everything changed
um and a lot of the industry so that's
what I want to share here um just
discuss you know a couple tips or things
actually that I went through
um and you know best practices to maybe
navigate your career better
um so let's let's get started
um so on the agenda we're gonna have a
little bit about me I'm gonna go through
um as I mentioned high level my degrees
but um how I actually move around and
how I actually was able to integrate
um multiple you know disciplines
um and actually the tech right
um and then we're going to have kind of
like kind of like the first tour about
that then we're gonna go through how can
I actually grow it right so how can I
actually grow my skills
um in Tech and then why right why those
skills are important nowadays right
which most of us will know that answer
um but I'm just gonna read a bit of a
lot of insight of my experience being
not in Tech and coming from a non-tech
background
um and then we're gonna go and welcome
anaconda's Cloud platform which we're
going to talk a little bit about what
starter and different things that are
really excited about anaconda and then
we're going to close and have some
questions and I want to make this really
interactive so please if you have any
questions Post in the house will
actually bring it to me I definitely
want to hear experiences if this
resonance with you
all right so who I am
um so I actually started my undergrad
doing civil engineer so totally not Tech
um and it was really traditional
engineer structural
um doing a lot of earthquake engineering
and then I'm from Puerto Rico so a lot
of earthquakes analysis and stuff and
that's when I first get started to
numerical analysis right
um it was a lot of modeling and then I
started doing a lot of like wave
modeling and I went I have a passion I
guess because I'm from an island but I
have a passion for wave and structure so
I was like how can I actually mix it too
um so I ended up getting a couple
internships and then jump to University
of Michigan where the closest to what I
wanted was the new architecture in our
engineered apartment
um and so I decided to go for my grad
school there and do food structure
interaction which is kind of like the
mix that I was looking for numerically
saw a lot of programming modeling and
software right behind the scenes but
with the actual technical background of
enable architecture
um and in the meantime I got a job with
Boeing so that's the reason that in the
middle I actually did a master's in
Aerospace so it's a little bit really
broad right because when I started I was
okay this is kind of what I want to do
um and then I wasn't boiling for a time
where it was all experimental so a lot
of like data Sensors how can we actually
have better you know data quality how do
we use that data to help our customers
to understand pretty much the aircraft
uh maintenance requirements so so it was
a big data I would call that at that
point
um it was not a nowadays it's a big
movement right but when I started Boeing
it was just collection of data we were
not thinking about how to do it optimize
you know better or optimize that
processes we just care about
record the data give me some results
that's it right so that's what I and
again everything start kind of like
fitting right as I was moving through my
career but started doing modeling then
big data or you know data acquisition
and how to store that and how to
actually use that for leverage for
information for what we wanted for the
aircraft in this case was fatigue and
then they were architecture where my PhD
was in fully structure interaction which
it was my first exposure to open source
I was doing cfd which is computational
for Dynamics and we were using open foam
at that time with my current advisor and
you know it was my first exposure to
Linux you know software Tech I would say
that was my first big big exposure to it
um but after all that now I'm actually
in tech industry
months and I will next slide we'll go
through why that happened or how was
everything fitting
um but I started doing a lot of data
science and software development
uh so that's overall who I am and I do
have a passion for reaching you know
doing research and education
um so my my journey to Tech as I
mentioned started doing Civil Air
creating Union modeling then I jumped to
my PhD where I was doing more chip
hydronomics doing open source
um where we were using like open foam
and that was where I learned about open
source right and believe it or not
before that in my under I never hear
about it um so I was like oh what is
that you know how that works why do we
have like free stuff right so that was
my first time that I started hearing and
it was cool to see that community and
the cfd getting together to get better
methods uh more faster methods right
that usually everybody complains about
see if they take so long so a lot of the
focus was how can we work together and
collaborate to make things better um the
benchmarking and avoid other people
doing the same things right at that that
point we were like we're implementing
packages or features and open foam we
don't want other folks doing cycle the
same thing so we started I started
getting that idea of a community right
um and and then again mentioned that was
my first exposure but at the same time I
was doing my Boeing
um because I did got a full-time offer
and they were great that they allowed me
to to do an educational leave of houses
I was like going back and forth so I was
like learning software coding
um at school but then doing data and
more experimental for full aircraft at
work so and it was a great combination
of the two but I was never linking both
of them so literally was I loaded and
that's the reason that I was it
resonates this topic to me in this
presentation because I was like we
sometimes have those
um occasions that we have like exposure
to things but we we don't do the
integration well or we don't know how to
integrate it right so
um that was one of my cases I was doing
pretty much big things or things that we
do in Tech nowadays right but I was
doing top really side loaded
um and then I jumped to
the offshore or oil and gas industry
based on my background in NATO
architecture
um so it was a fit so I came down to
Texas Houston and you can see that big
platform but I primarily my role was
facilities in here so I was designing
these platforms and when I got there
um and I am really grateful for our
co-worker uh Matt Kramer that he
actually been doing python for about
eight to nine years
um I was using Matlab C plus plus before
that a little bit of python
um but I will say when I got there to my
company
um he was already using Python and he
started like dude we we need to pair we
need to start doing you know cool stuff
with python and that's always my I will
say first jump into what python is
um and I love it because of the
community I mentioned the open source
community and that idea I embrace it
um so seeing the community in Python and
all this and this conferences right and
everybody collaborating was fascinating
for me
um so so that was one of the things that
I was like makes sense open source right
so we already know it's open source
comparing human licenses was a heart a
headache um sometimes over you know in a
private sector right it's like oh you
don't have enough license so you got to
wait there so I was like I got to learn
it so so I jumped to it and doing that a
lot of my science and my processes were
like okay
um how can I do my job better that's
when I that question started popping up
I was not in the tech industry but I was
an engineer really curious about tech
um but then I was more kind of inclined
to figure out how can I make my design
my processes my day-to-day easier faster
you know sometimes we have to make
turnarounds quick turnarounds we cost a
lot of money so how can I make that you
know less impactful for my company
um and less impossible for me right
because I have to go and a lot of the
processes were manual so we started
doing a lot of like optimization
um and everything was from python we'll
still do a lot of dashboarding data
science because we have tons tons tons
of data that were not on you that were
unused actually
um and then we started leveraging all
the data that we have from sensor so I
got involved on that and wound predicted
model so I got heavily into data science
for first I would say three years or
three years and a half
um and in a portion of that I was doing
predicting model for machine learning
um dashboarding or storytelling right
and it was it was a private sector right
so I have to
um have a business case for it right um
and talk to management and all that so
it was a lot of that and then the other
component was you're still an engineer
so you got to do your design your
analysis so we were using modeling and
we started doing wrappers
um and that's what I started getting
more into what software development is
we were doing like apis and wrappers to
apis to optimize our design and just to
pretty much do the full optimization of
all the different cases that we have to
run uh for for example that platform
there we will have a load case that
might be 500 400 a thousand cases and
you might only be changing one parameter
so you don't want to be clicking right
so so we start optimizing all that and
we create our own robbers internally so
it was written again
um that was like the first time that I
was able to start integrating everything
that I have learned in the past with my
day-to-day basis and then I jumped to to
Anaconda because I did wanted to keep
growing my skills and software data
science more heavily so it was the right
type of move and I decided you know I
just want to be in this industry out in
this community and learn more from each
other so that's a little bit of my story
and I will go a little more faster but
why do we need to grow skills in Tech
right
um if you think about it and we all
again have our own opinion of this but
one of the primary things is digital
transformation uh when I was in Yale and
gas industry it's a little bit slower of
an industry in terms of embracing new
technologies
um they also want to go to in this safe
zone right of things instead of the
experimenting new things and trying it
um so so it was harder to bring new
technologies and say hey you got to use
this machine learning for this right so
it was a little bit hard to sell
um but digital transformation I guess
all companies in the world are becoming
aware that we need to change the way
that we're doing things they're not
optimized we're doing a lot of money
process you know the scientific takes
months six to eight to maybe 10 where
you can if you incorporate a lot of
these tools you can actually do it in
about you know two three months maybe
right
um and then have more time for
provisions and you can have even more
design options to actually evaluate and
be more cost effective so all those
factors come into play and they're
becoming aware that we need to change
the way that we do things so when I was
there on my last year we did this big
figure of transformation
um and and part of it is like there were
pretty much in kind of embracing the
idea of avoiding silos and do
cross-collaboration right and we're
going to talk a little bit about that
but the I will say Agile development is
a big thing now also so before it was
like you have a design
at the beginning you go all the way
through that life cycle and then you're
done and then let's say that you have a
better option it's like well we already
spent 10 months right that was a lot of
money effort time
um and we're you know pretty much behind
schedule so we cannot do anything and
they just go right and maybe you have a
better option that you figure out
um and it's harder to improve for what
you did right so again they're also
embracing Agile development
um and this idea of doing trying
checking let's do it again and that's
how MVPs and this keep actually proven
right so so that is becoming kind of
like a DNA of a lot of the companies a
lot of the industries so again digital
transformation agile ideas and how we're
doing or is changing in all the
industries so we have to be aware of
that
um and the last thing is kind of like
everything the world is like the like
the internet of things right that's uh
that everybody uses but everything is
becoming digital nowadays um and as we
move you can see that Tech is getting
involved in every single field every
single industry so it's becoming kind of
like a must-have nowadays
um so so again digital transformation
the type of development in agile that
we're doing and kind of like being an
integrator of the technology with your
technical feel right so it's really
important so I think those will be the
more formal reasons why you got to learn
it now my takeaway which are personal
um facilitate just from job transition
so during the pandemic a lot of people
had to switch jobs right
um and they end up being a total
different industry
um not in what they used to wear for 10
15 years so this helps right because you
can adapt easier if you have that core
component of tech if you have that
mindset and you switch industry you
still have the mindset right so you
still will be thinking how can I
optimize my processes how can I do it
better how can I actually help my my
company to thrive right how can I
leverage all the information so
um a lot of that is actually part of it
or essential right in this process the
other thing is it supports this to the
process application as I mentioned it's
like how can I do my things better every
day it doesn't matter what you do but
how can I do it better right
um and be efficient at it and then
one big thing that I've been seeing is
like in the past it was a lot of focus
on having soccer matter experts in a
particular you know Focus area in I call
it like your Lane right and you stay in
that lane
um now they and that actually involve a
lot of silos right so you'll do your
thing when you're done you pass it over
it's like throwing it to the fence and I
experienced this in the Aerospace and
yellow and gas ET several actual
Industries and then the next person will
do their thing right
um and and we we husband talks that you
know maybe it's not the best way maybe
we need to collaborate better because
again we can optimize that process in
between and we can do better you know we
can have better options at the end I'm
not waiting towards the stuff all the
ends oh we got to change this and then
go back right so we need to have subject
matter experts
um but still those subject matter
experts can communicate through Tech as
I mentioned it can be the integrator
right so a lot of that can be can come
from using text skills right so it's
really important that you can still have
your own core of expertise don't get me
wrong but it's awesome if you learn Tech
tools and skills so that can help you to
integrate better with the
cross-functional fields right and the
last one is who don't want to be stable
and marketable right so
um during the pandemic if you have this
type of soft skills it was easier I
would not say easy but it was a little
bit easier than other folks and
candidates that didn't happen right
um because you have more skills right in
your in your belt that you can use right
and you can how they mentioned that
mindset can help you out so security
stability and like you know that guy on
the bottom jumping with the money is
like you know stability
um and it's really good to feel that
you're stable or that is a little bit
easier on a decision if something
happens right like it already happened
um so another question is like okay I
know it's important it makes sense uh
but how do you grow it
um and when I was doing this lie I
started thinking about it I was like
okay
um let me just put the chord oneself
teaching or self-learning code
challenges you know courses forums you
can do that then contributing to open
source is the big one so get involved
and you know repos follow them do books
and you will see may they might have a
tininess that you can help out and get
involved in that follow the community
and the trends so that's a big one
um big big big big one I would say it's
that third one learn by doing so just be
willing to pay risk try new things and
see how it goes right
um and then if it doesn't work at least
you know it doesn't work right so for
the next time when you have we're in a
very similar situation you'll know right
you will know that that's not an option
right so don't be willing to take those
risks and Learn by doing and the last
one is like reading and book clubs and
and actually you you can see that on
that um the book clubs is really
important and I just just started to
join one and it is awesome because you
can start getting and get that Community
feeling the exact you know industry you
can talk to The Experts of books and
stuff like that and learn from their
experiences right and their processes
like we're doing today in this talk so I
will say those are the formal ones that
I thought that I saw but still it's like
when I started even myself that I was
not a tech backer and it's like what I
wish for all right the things that I
will wear cool or if I did right
um and for me again this is really
personal but it was like no work to
start it's like it's a big industry it's
a big a lot of roles a lot of
Specialties right
um so where did I start right
um like which area should I do or things
like that so that's a big question right
on the certain that marketing needs for
me I will again it's kind of pretty
tight to that it's like what the market
is needing so what is the trend you know
what is the roles that are being pushed
or the need of the technology industry
to to keep pushing right the boundaries
so it's really important that we
understand that
um and then to do that it's like be part
of our community but then it's like
python yeah we have a big strong
Community but okay and it's a little bit
easier but if you're starting other
areas like the open foam and things like
this like how can I be part of that
Community you know how can I start
country we're going to be more involved
right and then leveraging your Tech
every day today has to mention it's like
sometimes we still get used to do things
the way that works or that we're used to
um and don't take those risks right and
try new things and if you are willing to
do that and start trying at your job
which is kind of what I did actually in
my own yes um and you know employer it's
like I think this is a good idea let me
just start trying to do things and
sometimes at work sometimes it didn't
right
um
thank thankfully most of the times they
did work right so it looks good but
still um I took those um you know
learnings and next time it's like no
we're not gonna do that I don't think
it's the best option because of this
learning that we have so
um and then make sure that what what do
you need to become marketable what I
mean there is like should I be a data
science should I be a software engineer
should it be you know they get an
engineer so so it's like again it's like
that understanding of what you like uh
what you expect long-term goals are uh
with your job even if you're not in tech
industry how can you mix it up it's a
big thing
um and the last thing will be
to pretty much is like try to understand
the market right the needs and how this
they're going and I think the balance
between those factors is what's going to
help you out and and this is something
that you learn by experience and again I
put those in there because there are
thoughts that I had when I was starting
and and it was hard it was hard to get
them all in one place or ask questions
or understand them right so you got to
go through it so I'm really happy to
announce right the internet companies
have a uh kind of like a release uh
something that would call the starter
tier
um and what it is so as I mentioned in
my bio I support nucleus right and
Anaconda nucleus is um one of the things
that is trying to get all those things
together into one right
um so as I mentioned you can be in a
book reading clubs you can be in forums
you can be on courses
um you can be on you know kind of like
uh podcast right and you can start
thinking about all the different areas
and it was hard to figure oh to only to
to get all of that in one place right so
so again where should I go where should
I start where should I follow and I
think the idea here with Anaconda
nucleus is to push right or help the
community to integrate a little bit more
right so it's like let's just try to get
um a centralized date and I call it like
a centralized data science but it's not
only data science right
um platform that you can pretty much
found all that in one place so it's
easier for you to get started right so
that's kind of like the main idea of
this
um and and now started here if you want
to start getting this because what we're
talking here in the stock is more about
how can I grow those skills right we
talk about why
um but how can I grow them or how where
to start or which area so I think this
was actually done for for those people
right for those persons
um it was more for people that don't
know how to start or don't have a good
idea how to start or make it easier for
even for experts right
um to help those other young folks that
want to start
um so we do have forums and now in third
tier they do have what is called
Anaconda learning and Anaconda notebooks
um and essentially in the learning it's
just a couple courses that we have and I
just kind of okay this is not actually
running so I will do it live really
quick
um but essentially we do have on on
Nucleus if you go there we're now going
to have like a suite of courses that you
can take
um and again it's created by experts not
only for now I think there has been
Anaconda employees but I think we open
maybe in the future for more people to
contribute so again that's what we want
we want our community getting together
and integrated we have forums that you
can go and participate and again what
we're trying to do is to help those
questions like okay what is the trend
um how can I move around if I want to
learn this what are the best options
right if I want to do that so so again
it doesn't have to be an anaconda
product just to be really clear what
we're trying to do is to help right to
integrate the community and it's a big
part of it and what I will do really
quick if I can is try to show this
really quick
um
let me just share my screen
and hope everybody can see that can
everybody see that
yes okay
um so yeah if you go there I'm already
log in with a cool thing it's like now
we have a couple courses so you can go
in there you can go by yourself and just
go and have different like self-learning
courses that you can go you have
different
um kind of like topics right so you can
jump around understand the courses
understand the authors right and again
um this will keep growing for now but we
have a couple of them but really
important now is you have like notebooks
in the cloud right so you don't have to
even install anything on your machine to
start programming and I just did a quick
example here when I uploaded uh Excel
file right where I have some data and I
just created my jupyter notebook and
really simple it's just that you start
running things here without even
figuring out you know anything you know
like installing packages or anything
like that so that is all done behind the
scenes so again what is it helps a lot
of new users to
um get familiarized with you know pretty
much programming follow the courses
um do their own thing day to day
um doesn't have to be right dude so now
data scientists have been using this for
a while
um to share right knowledge between them
but again you can do plotting you can do
a little bit of everything and I I don't
want to go through much into the product
but what I'm saying is like this are
type of things that I wish right
um that I had for a time and and let me
stop sharing right there really quick so
so those are the things that I wish I
had
um for a time and and it was hard to
find everything in one place and that's
what we're trying to actually
now kind of like
try to help integrate the community
right together on that and I think it's
a it's a great great tool if your
interest on it
um and then let me go really quick and I
re-share that presentation else I just
gotta share my screen and I can just
let's do that
um all right let me just wrap up the
last couple minutes but what I was now
is the closing thoughts so again as I
mentioned
um this stock was not about the product
it was more about
um actually understanding that we need
to be willing to explore new Fields
don't feel the pressure off I have to be
a subject matter expert in something I
think even for one of book clubs that um
I'm actually you know I'm a participant
on it was a question about should we be
learning about everything or should we
just uh more focusing on something and I
think kind of like the understanding is
that you can be a core to write expert
in one part but it's always good to
understand other areas around you so you
can help in that flow right and optimize
that processes so be willing to explore
in your fields and learn right how you
can do best books reading courses
mentoring whatever right
um but be willing to explore it right
one big thing that I learned about this
is take initiative
um and when I was doing all this
um again when I was in the oil and gas I
was taking courses right and I and I was
able to talk to my employer and say hey
I need support for this because I want
to do that so that's my third bullet
it's like ask for support right even for
your career employer
um let them know where your career goals
are the reason why you want to do it
um I bet that they're gonna embrace it
because nowadays you know if you have a
strong business case with tech and to
optimize processes why not right
um and then become part of the community
so that's really really really important
um be part of the community be active in
forums be active for you know in book
clubs or be active in you know packages
just just be there right conferences and
just contribute to this because that's
how we're building all this product and
this amazing familiar what python is
today is because of the community that
we have right so so keep it up right
um and really last one is be willing to
fail and keep trying I think that's
super super important
um it's really hard sometimes to to take
risks but it's important just to take
them right and not everything's gonna
work out all the time time but you need
to learn you're also going to learn
something positive from what we call a
failure which is not a failure right
it's a learning I like to to use that um
concept of learning instead of actually
saying that it's a failure right so
um so yeah hi Jose sorry to interrupt oh
I guess you're ending we're out of time
yeah yeah so no thank you very much for
everything thank you for your time and
if we have any time for questions so if
you have any questions uh let me know
and yeah here is my email and if you
want to contact me um thank you very
much for your time appreciate it